[Musica]
la contentezza
è uno stato d'animo è una parola
siciliana che per noi è fondamentale
aiuta a sopravvivere bene e a godersi la
vita per tutto il tempo la contentezza è
personale e autogena sta ciascuno di noi
di riceverla come un dono inaspettato
oppure cercarla nelle pieghe della vita
dell'animo o creare condizioni perché la
contentizza si manifesti e poi
mantenerla La vita è piena di alti e
bassi e nell'insieme La vita è bella Il
mondo è bello È come una pallina di
zucchero che addolcisce i dispiaceri La
solitudine e anche le paure La prima
contentizza è quella del neonato appena
nasce si attacca al seno della mamma e
poi isatollo dalla sua culla Osserva il
dondolio del fiocco che pende dalla
cappottina del passeggino il suo sguardo
lo segue gli occhi diventano lucidi sono
pieni di contentezza L'ho visto nei miei
due figli non credevo che fosse vero
Ma c'è altro nella contentezza C'è tanto
di altro nella contentezza la
contentezza dell'adulto Diletta
accarezza accende e soltanto su a nessun
altro se ne può impossessare è intima
silenziosa e potente
distende rasserena e mette di buon umore
come lo sguardo del neonato così la
contentezza dell'adulto si riconosce per
esempio dall'increspatura delle labbra
dal movimento delle palpebre dal
rilassamento del corpo di chi è preda
della contentezza e non ci abbandona ho
visto anziani che hanno perso la
capacità di comunicare con gli altri
Eppure capita che i loro occhi
tradiscono quel lume di contentizza che
è rimasto in Loro seguono le nuvole che
si rincorrono nel cielo la formica
sperduta su una pianta il movimento
involontario delle loro mani durante il
lockdown a Londra una vicina mi ha fatto
conoscere il suo gattino per nulla
timido ha cominciato a leccarmi la mano
con cura la lingua ruvida raspava le mie
dita e ad ogni piccola leccata mi
inondava di contentezza tra noi due il
gattino ed io sarà stabilito subito un
rapporto che superava la curiosità e
diventava Perfetto lui si dava a me Io
mi davo a lui gli animali sono
fondamentali nell'offrire con tintezza a
chi non riesce più a comunicare con i
suoi pari e ora in Inghilterra si parla
di dare animali agli anziani per
continuare a dare loro la contentezza
il lockdown a Londra è stato molto duro
ho pensato molto alla contentezza e ne
ho scritto con gioia e desiderio di vita
nonostante fossi sola nel mio
appartamento londinese perché ho fatto
questo perché la vita non sa negare la
bellezza perché stare al mondo fa bene
mi ha dolore alla vista dei mendicanti
di Londra nel quartiere in cui io vivo
poi vedo la gente che si ferma a fare
delle mosina altri si avvicinano e
scambiano parole altri ancora offrono
una sigaretta
ammiro quei londinesi che trattano i
mendicanti come se fossero loro pari
come se fossero amici che si soffermano
e chiacchierano più del meno col
mendicante per un popolo rinomato per la
sua
presunzione per la sua riservatezza la
dimostrazione al contrario mi rende
fiera di essere diventata anch'io
Britannica
e mi viene anche Allora un'ondata di
contentezza Ma cos'è sta contentezza i
miei figli me lo chiedono mamma di che
parli è amore perché senza amore non c'è
nulla di bello e di buono nel mondo la
contentizza anche moderazione non è
risata fragorosa non è grande gioia e
non è legata alla ricchezza materiale
la contentezza e la cugina stretta delle
piccole cose che rendono la vita
sopportabile per chi soffre e lo aiutano
ad uscirne quando era alle elementari
mamma diceva quando finisci i compiti Ti
do il contentino che era un biscotto con
sopra la marmellata e io ero al settimo
cielo Quando frequentavo le medie c'era
un'altra contentezza mamma prendeva il
caffè amaro come sua madre e come faccio
io ora per i bambini lei faceva cadere
una gocciolina di caffè nella
zuccheriera poi la scuoteva e la pallina
diventava superficie di confetto
marroncino dolcissimo che lei prendeva
con il cucchiaino
lo teneva in equilibrio e mi diceva
avvicinati e me lo metteva in bocca che
contentezza
indimenticabile Esistono però anche i
nemici della contentezza Quelli si
sentano esclusi ci sono i gelosi quelli
che sono incapaci di godersi la vita e
che non vogliono vedere gli altri che
gioiscono o addirittura vogliono evitare
gli avvenimenti gioiosi della propria
vita e quella dei propri familiari
quelli che accettano l'invito a un
compleanno e poi non ci vanno quelli che
arrivano si sentono e non fanno
null'altro quelli che ti guardano con
gli occhi
che sembrano semi morti ma in realtà
sono pieni di cattiveria esistono
li ho visti nelle classi alte i maschi
maggiori sono i preferiti e i minori ne
soffrono e li invidiano poi trovano
conforto nel rancore nella gelosia e
infine nel pettegolezzo Uomini e Donne
le zitelle erano un tempo
particolarmente acido invidiose non
lavoravano ed erano mantenute dalla
famiglia alla morte dei genitori le
zitelle non vivevano con la sorella
maritata Ma andavano a vivere dal
fratello sposato dove erano sottoposte
alla volontà e le angherie della cognata
con cui i rapporti erano spesso molto
tesi reagivano con sospiri con smorfie
la bocca in giù lo sguardo dall'alto in
basso
il momento di gloria delle zitelle sono
i funerali e i matrimoni lì davanti ai
parenti amici possono darsi aria possono
guastare con una mezza frase e
un'atmosfera di gioia e di dolore
dobbiamo anche capirle queste zitelle
costrette a non lavorare a stare con un
parente con cui non vogliono che non
hanno un futuro è triste
oggi viviamo tutti tutti con la paura di
un'altra guerra mondiale oggi vediamo
bruttura in tutto il mondo e la
televisione la tecnologia che ce le fa
vedere sentire e leggere
è un mondo brutto ma non dobbiamo
dimenticare la contentezza tuttora
Esiste la contentezza incoraggia ad
aiutare e rifugiati costretti a scappare
dalle loro terre bombardate l'abbiamo
visto quanto è stata generosa la nostra
Europa con questi rifugiati dall'ucraina
non possiamo dimenticarlo vogliamo
copiarli
mia madre mi ha insegnato che l'amaro
può diventare dolce basta volerlo tutti
siamo capaci di averla Ma contentizza
chi crede di non averla mai conosciuta è
bene che torni sui suoi passi c'è e si
può veramente cercare non c'è età o
condizione sociale a negarla è lì che ci
aspetta la contentezza E non
dimentichiamo che la contentezza nostra
si trasferisce agli altri ti trasferisce
ai nostri vicini ai nostri bambini si
trasferisce al marito alla moglie con
cui abbiamo avuto un bisticcio la
contentezza è contagiosa e fa bene a
tutti
addolcire il cibo incoraggia dal
addolcire la vita quando essa diventa
insopportabile anche lì bisogna pensare
alla contentezza bisogna farlo bisogna
addolcire il cibo e addolcire la vita
perché la vita
può migliorare perché la fedele
convintizza È lì che la protegge e che
conforta le famiglie che hanno
difficoltà le coppie che non sanno cosa
fare i bambini perplessi e confusi Io mi
auguro che qualcuno di voi stasera abbia
rincontrato la contentezza degli anni
passati e che la accetti ne gode Vi
auguro di pensare alla contentizza
passata e a quella Futura e di
insegnarlo ai vostri amici ai vostri
figli e mi auguro che altri desiderano
incontrarla per la prima volta c'è gente
che non la conosce è sempre dentro di
noi la contentezza pronta ad affiorare e
non fa mai male grazie
[Applauso]